we had a had to take
big dog to Thailand years ago and uh we
did this great video of the robot
walking in the sand walking into the
ocean up to I don't know its belly or
something like that and then turning
around and walking out all while playing
some cool beach music yeah great show
but then you know we didn't really clean
the robot off and the salt water was
really hard on it so you know we put it
in a box shipped it back by the time it
came back we had some problems with salt
it's the salt water it's not like old
stuff it's not like sand getting into
the components or something like this
but I'm sure if if this is a big
priority you can make it like waterproof
right that just wasn't our our goal at
the time well it's a personal goal of
mine to it walk along the beach but it's
a human problem too you get sand
everywhere it's it's just a jam mess
so soft surfaces are okay so I mean can
we just uh link on the the robotics
challenge there's a there's a pile of uh
like Rubble they had to walk over is
that's
um how difficult is that task
in the early days of developing big dog
the loose Rock was the epitome of the
hard walking surface because he stepped
down and then the Rock and you had these
little Point feet on the robot
and The Rock can roll and and you have
to deal with that last minute you know
change in your foot placement yes so you
step on the thing and that thing
responds to you stepping on it yeah and
and it moves where your point of support
is and so it's really that that became
kind of the essence of the test and so
that was the beginning of us starting to
build Rock piles in our parking lots and
and we would actually build boxes full
of rocks and bring them into the lab and
then we would have the robots walking
across these boxes of rocks because that
became the essential test
so you mentioned big dog can you can we
maybe take a stroll through the history
of Boston Dynamics uh so what and who's
Big Dog by the way is who
do you try not to anthropomorphize the
robots do you try not to to try to
remember that they're this is like the
division I have because I for me it's
impossible
for me there's a magic to the to the
being that is a robot it is not human
but it is
the the same Magic
uh the living being has when it moves
about the world is there in the robot so
um I don't know what question I'm asking
but uh should I say what or who I guess
who is Big Dog what is big dog
well I'll say to address the medic
question
we don't try to draw hard lines around
it being an it or a him or a her
um it's okay right people I think part
of the magic of these kinds of machines
is by nature of their organic movement
of the of their Dynamics
we tend to want to identify with them we
tend to look at them and sort of
attribute
maybe feeling to that because we've only
seen things that move like this that
were alive
and so
um this is an opportunity it means that
you could have
a feelings for a machine and you know
people have feelings for their cars you
know they get attracted to them attached
to them so that's inherently could be a
good thing as long as we manage what
that interaction is
so we don't put strong boundaries around
this and ultimately think it's a benefit
but it's also can be a bit of a curse
because I think people look at these
machines
and they attribute a level of
intelligence that the machines don't
have why because again they've seen
things move like this that we're living
beings
which are intelligent
and so they want to attribute
intelligence to the robots that isn't
appropriate yet even though they move
like an intelligent being but you try to
acknowledge that the
anthropomorphization is there and try to
first of all acknowledge that it's there
and have a little fun with it you know
our most recent video
it's just kind of fun you know to to
look at the robot we started off the the
video with Atlas
um kind of looking around for where the
bag of tools was because the guy up on
the scaffolding says send me some tools
Atlas has to kind of look around and see
where they are and there's a little
personality there that is fun it's
entertaining it makes our jobs
interesting and I think in the long run
can enhance interaction between humans
and robots that in a way that isn't
available to machines that don't move
that way this is something to me
personally is very interesting I've been
um
I happen to have a lot of legged robots
I hope to have a lot of spots in my
possession
um I'm interested in celebrating
Robotics and celebrating companies and I
also don't want to companies that do
incredible stuff like Boston Dynamics
and I there's a
you know I'm a little crazy and you say
you don't want to you you want to align
you want to help the company because I
ultimately want a company that busted an
image to succeed and part of that will
talk about you know success kind of
requires making money
and so the kind of stuff I'm
particularly interested in may not be
the thing that makes money in the short
term I can make an argument they will in
the long term but the kind of stuff I've
been playing with is a robust way of uh
having the quadruples the robot dogs
communicate emotion with their body
movement the same kind of stuff you do
with it with a dog but not not
hard-coded uh but in a robust way and be
able to communicate excitement or fear
boredom all this kind of stuff and I
think as a base layer
of function of behavior to add on top of
a robot I think that's a really powerful
way uh to make the robot more usable for
humans for whatever application it's
going to be really important and um it's
a thing we're we're beginning to pay
attention to
um we really want to start a
differentiator for the company has
always been we really want the robot to
work we want it to be useful
uh
making it work at first meant the legged
Locomotion really works it can really
get around and it doesn't fall down and
um but beyond that and now it needs to
be a useful tool and our customers are
for example Factory owners people who
are running a process manufacturing
facility and the robot needs to be able
to get through this complex facility in
a reliable way you know taking taking
measurements
we need for people who are operating
those robots to understand what the
robots are doing
if the robot gets into needs help or or
you know is in trouble or something it
needs to be able to communicate
and a physical indication of some sort
so that a person looks at the robot and
goes oh I know what that's that robot's
doing the robot's going to go take
measurements of my vacuum pump with its
thermal camera
you know you want to be able to indicate
that and or even just the robots
um about to turn you know in front of
you and maybe indicate that it's going
to turn and so you sort of see and can
anticipate its motion so these this kind
of communication is going to become more
and more important it wasn't sort of our
starting point
um you know but now the the robots are
really out in the world and you know we
have about a thousand of them out with
with customers right now
this layer of physical indication I
think is going to become more and more
important we'll talk about where it goes
because there's a lot of interesting
possibilities but if you can return back
to the origins of Boston and Dynamics
with so that the more research the r d
side before we talk about how to build
robots at scale so big dog so um who's
Big Dog so the company started in 1992.
and in um probably uh uh 2003
I believe is when we uh took a contract
from darpto basically 10 years 11 years
um we weren't doing robotics we did a
little bit of Robotics with Sony they
had uh IBO the their IBO robot we were
developing some software for that that
kind of got us a little bit involved
with robotics again then there's this
opportunity to do a DARPA contract where
they wanted to build
a robot dog and uh we we won a contract
to build that and so that was the
Genesis of big dog
and it was a quadruped and it was the
first time we built a robot that had
everything on board that you could
actually take the robot out into the
wild and operate it so it had onboard
power plant it had onboard computers it
had
hydraulic actuators that needed to be
cooled so we had cooling systems built
in
everything integrated into the robot
and uh that was a pretty rough start
right it was it was 10 years that we
were not a robotics company we were a
simulation company and then we had to
build a robot in about a year so that
was a little bit of a rough transition
um
I mean can you just comment on the
roughness of that transition because uh
big dog I mean this is just big
uh quadruped four legs robot rebuilt a
few different versions of them but the
first one the very earliest ones you
know it didn't work very well and we
would take them out and it was hard to
get you know uh
you know a go-kart engine driving a
hydraulic that's not what it was
and and you know uh having that all work
uh while trying to get you know the
robot to stabilize itself and so what
was the power plan what was the engine
it seemed like uh my vague direct
collection
I don't know it felt very loud and
aggressive and uh kind of thrown
together that's what it kind of oh it
absolutely was right we weren't trying
to design the best robot Hardware at the
time and uh we wanted to buy an
off-the-shelf engine and so many of the
early versions of big dog had literally
go-kart engines or something like that
usually gas power like a yeah gas
powered two-stroke engine
and the reason why it was two-stroke is
two-stroke engines are lighter weight
but they're also and we we generally
didn't put Mufflers on them because
we're trying to save the weight and we
didn't care about the noise and so these
things were horribly loud
um but we're trying to manage weight
because managing weight in a legged
robot is always important because it has
to carry everything
that said that thing was big well I've
seen the videos yeah I mean the the
early versions you know stood about I
don't know belly High chest High
um you know they probably weighed maybe
a couple of hundred pounds but you know
it over the course of probably five
years
we are able to get that robot
to really manage a remarkable level of
rough terrain so you know we started out
with just walking on the flat and then
we started walking on rocks and then
inclines and then mud and slippery mud
and you know by the end of that program
we were convinced that legged Locomotion
in a robot could actually work because
you know going into it we didn't we
didn't know that we had built quadrupeds
at at MIT
but they were they used a giant
hydraulic pump you know in the lab they
used a giant computer that was in the
lab they were always Tethered to the lab
this was the first time something that
was sort of self-contained you know
walked around in the world
and balance but and then the purpose was
to prove to ourselves that the leg of
locomotion could really work and so um
big dog really cut that open for us and
it was the beginning of what became a
whole series of robots so once once we
showed to darpan that you could make it
like a robot that could work there was a
period that DARPA where robotics got
really hot and there was lots of
different programs
and you know we were able to build other
robots we built other quadrupeds to hand
like LS3
designed to carry heavy loads we built
cheetah which was designed to explore
what are the limits to how fast you can
run you know we began to build sort of a
portfolio
of machines and software that let us
build not just one robot but a whole
family everyone to push the limits in
all kinds of directions yeah and to
discover those principles you know you
asked earlier about the Art and Science
of a leg and locomotion
we it were able to develop principles of
legged Locomotion so that we knew how to
build
a small legged robot or a big one so the
leg like length you know was now a
parameter that we could play with
payload was a parameter we could play
with so we built the LS3 which was an
800 pound robot designed to carry a 400
pound payload
and we we learned the design rules
basically developed the design rules how
do you scale different robot systems to
you know their terrain to their walking
speed to their payload